Here's my answer.
The first thing I did,
was to fill in the diagonals.
These should all be 0 unless
there's a negative cycle.
Thankfully, there's only one
negative path found so far, and
I can easily check that it
doesn't create a negative cycle.
When we use 4 as an intermediate vertex,
I could go from 3 to 4,
that would cost -3.
But going back from 4 to 3 would cost 6,
and so
then the overall cost would
be 3 which is greater than 0.
0 is better.
Next, I filled in the values where 4
was either a source or a destination,
since vertex 4 can't help as an
intermediate vertex in those situations.
Now for the remaining entries.
The choices for going from 1 to 3
are either to use the old path,
which costs 4, or to go from 1 to 4.
And then from 4 to 3, that costs 7.
So, the old path is better.
How about going 2 to 1?
Well, there is no old path.
But there is a path through 4.
I could go from 2 to 4,
that would cost 1.
And then from 4 to 1, which would
cost 2 more, for a total of 3.
That's good.
Going from 2 to 3 was impossible before,
but
using vertex 4,
I can go 2 to 4 for a cost of 1.
And then 4 to 2 for
a cost of 6 more for a total of 7.
3 to 1 is another path that's
impossible without going through 4.
But if I do go through 4,
then going 3 to 4 costs -3.
And going 4 to 1 costs 2,
for a total of -1.
Lastly, we have that going from
3 to 2 used to cost 2, but
we can improve on that,
by going to 4 first, which costs -3.
And then going form 4 to 2,
which costs 1, for a total of -2.
And that completes the answer.